Speaker 1: There was a whacked out event at
Trump's Doral Resort in Florida, where Dr.
Peter McCullough, one of the big we, I guess I
would call him like an anti-vax pseudoscience
dignitary who rose in the age of COVID. Dr. Peter
McCullough. See if you can follow this. Okay. He
suggested at this completely bonkers event. The
COVID vaccines cause autism. Autism turns people
trans. Therefore using our. What is that the
commutative property from algebra pre-algebra
therefore vaccinations cause trans. This is
really weaponized stuff. It must be something
happening to the children. Something in the.
Speaker 3: In the air and the water or the food.
Speaker 1: One theory is that it's hyper.
Speaker 3: Vaccination.
Speaker 1: From an accelerating childhood.
Speaker 3: Vaccines.
Speaker 1: Schedule. Huh. So he's
saying it's vaccines in general,
not even just the COVID vaccine. A theory. It's
not really a theory. We spoke about this yesterday
on the voicemail. It's not actually a theory in
the scientific sense. It's the idle speculation
of someone who has no basis in fact for making the
claim. But we should have an all hands on deck.
Oh, yeah. Manhattan Project to figure out what
is causing autism and how can we stop it? Because
once it's present, I can tell you as a doctor,
it's very difficult to treat. And as a parent,
any of you with autistic children know as a
parent, it can take everything you have as a
person, sometimes for the rest of your.
Speaker 3: Life as a couple, to deal.
Speaker 1: With a severely autistic.
Speaker 3: Affected child.
Speaker 1: All of you know that.
Speaker 3: Autism now.
Speaker 1: Is critically linked as these children.
Speaker 3: Are coming forward in large numbers
to transgenderism.
Speaker 1: Whoa. The two are linked.
Imagine cheering for that. So do an inventory
of what you have. Do an inventory of your
family. Any of your friends. Gather together
and understand this mental contagion is.
Speaker 3: Infectious and it's.
Speaker 1: Spreading. And
we've seen the chapters now.
Speaker 3: COVID, the illness. COVID vaccination,
a wave of autism that's just.
Speaker 1: Burning us.
Speaker 3: And now.
Speaker 1: Transgenderism.
All right. So again, the argument he's making is
vaccines cause autism. Autism causes trans. Now,
a little background on Dr. Peter McCullough.
He regularly has spread baseless and ultimately
debunked medical misinformation. He's a
cardiologist. He said we should be using
hydroxychloroquine for treating COVID. That
was determined. He said that at a time when
there was no actual good science, saying that
that was effective. We ultimately found out
hydroxychloroquine is not effective for COVID. He
did the same thing with ivermectin at a time when
we didn't have a reason to believe Ivermectin was
a fact that ultimately a double blind, randomized,
controlled trials determined ivermectin is not
effective. And on and on and on. Now, let's talk
about a couple of different things here. First
of all, the wave of autism. There is a question
and we're going to actually do an interview on
the show about this coming up. Is there really
more and more autism or are we now understanding
how to better diagnose it? And there were lots of
people who 20 years ago would never have been
diagnosed, but they were autistic. I've spoken
to friends of mine about classmates we had in
third, fourth grade, and we now realize and they
have since been diagnosed as autistic in their
twenties and thirties. They were always autistic.
It just wasn't understood as well at the time.
And so there's a question as to whether there
is a wave of autism or the diagnostic criteria
are better understood regardless. There's no
evidence that vaccines cause autism. This all goes
back to 1998. Doctor Andrew Wakefield put a study
out in the Lancet prestigious medical journal.
The study has since been retracted and Wakefield
has lost his license, It claimed, on the basis of
12 children that there was a link between the MMR
vaccine and autism. The study was retracted.
Wakefield was found guilty of fraud, ethical
violations, financial conflicts of interest.
The data was biased, selective and falsified,
and he lost his medical license. Even if vaccines
caused autism, which they don't. There is no
logical or biological reason why autism would turn
people trans. Some autistic people may identify
as trans. Most don't. Some trans people may be
autistic. Most are not. There is no evidence that
vaccines cause autism and that autism influences
gender identity. But this is a hero to the MAGA,
right? This is the MAGA Republican, right?
At an event held at Trump's Doral Resort.